اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم اقدم اليكم هذه المقابله الخاصه من
اسطنبول مع دوجو برينشيك رئيس حزب الوطن
اليساري التركي اهلا بكم معنا سيد برينجيك
على شاشه العربيه
ما حقيقه موقفكم من التحالفات الانتخابيه
الحاليه توصفون احيانا بانكم الحديث الخفي
لاردوغان رغم انه لم يضمك الى تحالفه
الانتخابي كيف نفسر ذلك
التحالف بين تركيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهذا يحدد المواقف تجاه الاخيره
ونحن حزب حازم ومتزن حيالها والرئيس
اردوغان تجنب التحالف معنا خشيه من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا انتم
تنفون انكم حليف خفي لاردوغان نحن لسنا
حليفا خفيا لاردوغان وقد كان من قبل رئيسا
مشاركا لمشروع الشرق الاوسط الكبير الذي
طرحته الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونحن من
خلصناه من ذلك وجذبناه الى جانب شعوب
الشرق الاوسط وتازرنا نجاح يكتب لنا اذا
يعني انتم الذين او من الذين قربتموه الى
هذا المشروع وبالتالي يعني علاقاتكم به
ليست سيئه
اردوغان تحول فعلا الى يعني او حول تركيا
الى المعسكر الشرقي قليلا دون ان يخسر
تحالفاته مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
التي تناهضونها بشده هنا اريد ان اسالك
تحديدا
هل تعتقد بانه لا يزال هناك دوله عميقه في
تركيا يمثلها بعض الاطراف وحضرتك شخصيا
قرات على بعض المواقع وصفا لك يقولون انك
رجل الدوله العميقه في تركيا
تركيا
كانت موجوده في فتره هيمنه حلف شمال
الاطلسي الناتو والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكنها سحقت في ليله الخامس عشر
من يوليو تموز وزيت في السجون وكان لنا
دور رائد في ذلك وبالتالي نحن تلك القوه
التي قامت بتصفيه دوله الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه العميقه في تركيا والتي كنا
نناضل حيالها منذ 50 عاما وقد سبق لي ان
قبعت في سجونهم ست سنوات ونحن في حزب
الوطن من طلائع مق دوله التركيه والامه
التركيه
لدوله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه العميقه
في تركيا ولكن ما يقال في الواقع انها
كانت
اشبه بالتمثيليه او المسرحيه التي قام بها
اردوغان
ليبسط نفوذه وسيطرته على كل مفاصل الدوله
ولكي يعني يجهز على كل ما تبقى من اثار
الدوله العلمانيه الاته تركيا وحضرتك ترفع
صور اتاتورك وكمالي بامتياز كيف نفسر ذلك
اليس هناك شيء من التناقض بين كل هذه
العناوين التي تجمعها حضرتك
في الواقع من يصفونها بالمسرحيه هم من
يمثلون كيف يكون ذلك وقد فقدنا فيها اكثر
من 250 مواطنا في المسرحيات الناس لا تموت
حقيقه وها هنا الناس ماتوا حقيقه وهناك
اكثر من 2000 مصعب خرجت المدرعات من
ثقناتها وحلقت الطائرات فلا شيء منها
محبوك وخيالي وهذا من تلفيق الطرف الاخر
وقد كانت المحاوله الانقلابيه حربا بين
تركيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
شوارع اسطنبول وانقره ولم تكن مسرحيه نحن
نناضل لتكتمل الثوره الاتاتركيه والكماليه
اي لاجل اكتمال الثوره الوطنيه
الديمقراطيه التركيه وكذلك نناضل ايضا من
اجل الشعوب العربيه لرفع رايه الاخوه
والتكاتف والتضامن مع فلسطين وتاسيس
دولتها المستقله والموحده وعاصمتها القدس
نناضل ايضا لانهاء التدخل الامريكي في
سوريا وتعزيز اواصر الاخوه مع دول الخليج
العربي والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والحيلوله دون تهديد قناه السويس ومضيق
هرمز من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لم استطع ان افهم بعد مع كل هذه
الاختلافات والانتقادات
للسيد رجب طيب اردوغان وحكومته ولكل ما
يحصل في الدوله التركيه مؤخرا وحضرتك
تساعد الحكومه وتعتبر مستشارا سياسيا
لسياسه الخارجيه على الاقل لها كيف ذلك
اردوغان يتذبذب ولا يتخذ موقفا ثابتا حيال
الامبرياليه الامريكيه فعندما ننظر الى
سياسته الخارجيه في سوريا نجد ان هناك
اتجاهين داخل حزب العداله والتنميه
الاتجاه الاول ينحاز الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والثاني يؤيد الانحياز الى
سوريا والعراق وايران وروسيا ونحن ها هنا
نتبع سياسه حازمه وثابته ونسع الى التاثير
على الرئيس اردوغان لسنا مستشارين له لكن
نحن قوه مؤثره في السياسه التركيه وندافع
عن الصداقه مع الدول العربيه والشرق
اوسطيه
الحزب مؤثر ولكن بدون قواعد شعبيه كبرى
وهذا ما يعزى اليه او يعزى اليه البعض عدم
ضم اردوكان لكم
في تحالفه الانتخابي اضافه الى سبب اخر
نناقشه معك بعد الفاصل ولكن ما ردك على
هذه النقطه الان
ليس بسبب قله الدعم الشعبي لنا فحسبنا
يحظى بدعم جماهيري كبير بل لخشيته من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتجنبا
للعقوبات الامريكيه في حال التحالف معنا
كنت اريد كما قلت قبل الفاصل ان اتابع معك
في بعض الاسباب التي حالت دون يعني ان
يضمكم اردوغان الى تحالفه
رغم كل الاختلافات المعروفه ولكن السياسه
تجمع احيانا هناك سبب اخر يقال
يعني انكم سجنتم سابقا لست سنوات من 2008
في
قضيه ارجانيكان
واضافه الى ضم حزبكم لشخصيه كثيره تورطت
في محاوله انقلابيه وجزء منها تلك التي
اطاحت بالنجم الدين اربكان الزعيم او الاب
الروحي لاردوغان الذي عمل معه وانطلق من
حزبه كيف يمكن ان ترد على هذا ايضا
رجل طيب اردوغان كان انذاك مع عصابه فتح
الله جولنا الارهابيه التي نسقت مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وزجوني في
السجن رجب طيب اردوغان كان يومها مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن نحن قدمنا
نضالا كبيرا ودخلت تركيا في مرحله التخلص
من الهيمنه الامريكيه ثم ما لبث ان انفصل
اردوغان عن فتح الله جولن وبدا يقاوم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانتقل الى
طرفنا وبالتالي صار هناك اختلاف في موقف
اردو لكن ما يزال هناك في حزب العداله
والتنميه توجهات توجه امريكي وتوجه تركي
واردوغان يروح ويغضوا بينهما ولخشيته من
امريكا تجنب خوض الانتخابات معنا
ولكن يعني ذكرت في هذه الحلقه القصيره
عمليا كلمه امريكا
يعني لا ادريك كم مره اكثر من عشر مرات
ربما
يعني اكثر مما ذكرت تركيا او اكثر مما
ذكرت اردوغان او التحالفات الاخرى اليس
هذا تحميل الامر اكثر مما يحتمل خاصه مع
كل السياسات المختلفه عن الولايات المتحده
التي اتبعها اردوغان التي ابعدته عن
واشنطن وقربته اكثر من المعسكر الشرقي اذا
صح التعبير يعني بالعصر الحالي امير
نحن نعارض الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لانها تفرض هيمنتها على
وتستخدمها لغاياتها الامبرياليه وهذا يضر
تركيا في تطوير اقتصاد مستقل ويهدد امنها
وها هي اليوم تاسس قواعد عسكريه على
السواحل اليونانيه وها هي اليوم تؤسس
قواعد عسكريه على السواحل اليونانيه
ولديها اساطيل حربيه شرقي المتوسط موجهه
فوهاتها صوب تركيا وبالتالي صارت تركيا
وامريكا وجها لوجه ويوم كانت تركيا وراء
امريكا احدثت الاخيره انقلابات عسكريه
وهذا يظهر ان هناك تناقضا موضوعيا بين
تركيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولهذا
السبب نعادي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وهذا يصب لصالح تركيا والدول العربيه في
الوقت ذاته من الذي يحول دون التلاحم
العربي التركي اليست امريكا فالصداقه
العربيه التركيه مهمه لمست في تركيا
ولكن اذا سمحت لي سيد يعني انت حتى تحالف
الامه تحالف المعارض لاردوغان تطلق عليه
تحالف بايدن يعني هل كل التحالفات
السياسيه الاساسيه في تركيا كل حكام تركيا
تابعون للولايات المتحده الى هذه الدرجة
اليس هذا يعني تخوينا واتهاما بالعماله
وبالتالي لن يكون الا قله قليله انت تحسب
نفسك منهم يعني هم اتراك محض وليسوا
تابعين للغرب بجمد
غالبيه الشعب التركي اليوم حوالي 80
وتسعين بالمئه منهم وفق استطلاعات الراي
معادون للولايات المتحده الامريكيه الشعب
التركي يرى ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تهديد لتركيا وبالتالي نحن لسنا وحيدين
واردوغان يتاثر بهذا حيث تخلى عن موقفه
القديم واص الى جانب الشعب التركي يمكنني
ان ابين ذلك بطريقه اخرى ماذا حدث في
الاونه الاخيره انفكت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ودول الخليج عن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبدات باقامه علاقات وطيده مع
ايران واسيا والصين فانتم الان في
السعوديه ودول الخليج تعيشون المراحل التي
عشناها في تركيا العالم يتغير الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في حاله انحدار وبدات
تفقد نفوذها القديم وبدات تركيا والدول
العربيه تخرج عن الهيمنه الامريكيه هذه
مرحله ويمكننا ان نقيم اردوغان ضمن هذه
المرحله
لا ادري اذا كانت كلمه انسحاب بعض الدول
العربيه من التحالف مع امريكا هي الكلمه
الصحيحه ولكن يعني هم لهم رايهم المعلن في
ذلك عموما فيما يتعلق بالوضع الداخلي
التركي اذا لم تقبلوا تحالف الجمهور ولا
تقبلون بتحالف الامه اي تركيا تريدون يعني
ما الذي تريدونه لتركيا وما الذي تتوقعونه
بخصوص النتائج
التحالفان ليس متساويين تحالف الامه تحت
الهيمنه الامريكيه بشكل كامل واداه بيدها
اما تحالف الجمهور فليس كذلك لكنه يخشى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كيف يصح ان تكون علمانيا وقت تركيا وفي
الوقت نفسه معاديا الى هذا الحد للغرب
واتاتورك هو الذي فتح تركيا باتجاه الغرب
وكل يعني التعاليم التي اسسها
هذا ليس بصحيح اتاتورك ناضل ضد الغرب
وحاربهم لكنه كان متمسكا بالقيم الثوريه
الغربيه العصريه وانما عاد الامبرياليه
الغربيه حارب الامبرياليه الغربيه لينفر
بالقيم الديمقراطيه الثوريه الغربيه ولكن
انتم ذهبتم بعيدا اكثر بكثير ويعني انتم
فكركم دائما شيوعي يساري بشكل كبير
ومع المعسكر الروسي قلبا وقالبا حاليا في
موضوع اوكرانيا في موضوع سوريا في كل
مواضيع التي تتعلق بمنطقتنا
لماذا لا تاخذون جانبا مت اكثر يرضي جميع
الاطراف ويؤدي الى السلام لا الى الحرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تترك لنا
طريقا وسطا امريكا اتت واسست قواعدها على
السواحل اليونانيه وتدعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني الارهابي وتنظيم جولينا
الارهابي في تركيا وبالتالي لا تترك لنا
طريقا وسطا لذلك نحن مضطرون
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لحمايه وطننا
وصونه وتاسيس تركيا المنتجه المزدهره هذا
ياخذكم الى المعسكر الشرقي تماما ولكن
السؤال هو انتم رجل قانون في الاساس كيف
يستقيم ان يكون لكم كل هذه المواقف
المتطرفه ضد الحزب العمال الكردستاني وليس
فقط حتى لو كان ذلك مفهوما تركيا الا انه
ايضا ضد
الاجور في الصين
وتشبهونهم بحزب العمال الكردستاني ايضا
معروف عنكم طبعا كانكم تنكرون المجازر كما
تعرف بين قوسين ضد الارمن وهذا موقف ايضا
قد يكون مفهوما تركيا ولكن على الصعيد
القانوني كيف يمكن ان تقبل به حضرتك
تركيا الانجليزيه
مع مستقبل تركيا ولا توسط في ذلك اما قضيه
ايغور فقد احدثت لتقسيم الصين وامريكا
تدعم ارهابي ايغور وحزب العمال الكردستاني
تنظيم ارهابي يحظى بدعم امريكي كامل
يريدون تاسيس اسرائيل الثانيه دوله
كردستان التي ينبون تاسيسها هي اسرائيل
الثانيه ولن تكون دوله كرديه وهذا ليس
لمصلحتنا جميعا ودوله كردستان التي
يعتزمون تاسيسها تقع في اراضي عربيه
سيقتطعون جزءا من سوريا وجزء من العراق
وجزءا من ايران وتركي
هو جزء من سؤال سابق لم تجبني عليه حضرتك
ماذا تتوقعون للنتائج نتائج الانتخابات
التركيه
امريكا
ستنتصر تركيا وستفشل مخططات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وامريكا لن تقبل نتائج
هذه الانتخابات وتتهيا لعدها غير مشروعه
وتجهز لثوره برتقاليه كما حدث في جورجيا
واوكرانيا وتركيا ستتغلب على ذلك كله
وسيلهزم الطرف الامريكي وينتصر الطرف
التركي
هذا يضطرني الى الذهاب الى سؤال اخر ماذا
يعني تملكون من معلومات كما تقول بشان نيه
الولايات المتحده الاعتراض على نتائج
الانتخابات اذا فاز تحالف الجمهور بقياده
اردوغان تركيا
تسير وراء قياده اردوغان ولم تخرج عن
مسارها ابدا واردوغان مضطر ان يكون مع
اسيا ومع الصين وروسيا وايران والدول
العربيه والاسبيل امام اردوغان سوى هذا
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذا اللقاء سيد الدوجو
برينجيك رئيس حزب الوطن التركي اليساريه
شكرا جزيلا لوجودك معنا
مشاهدينا الكرام هكذا نكون قد وصلنا اذا
الى ختام هذه المقابله الخاصه من اسطنبول
مع دوغو برينجيك رئيس حزب الوطن التركي
اليساريه شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب
للاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات